hi everybody my name is caleb banks I'm
15 years old and this is my crazy hi I'm
Philip banks and I'm her dad not the
crazy part so we're to talk about kind
of what Jim hit on is how to raise a
family in tech but it's so much more
than that it's about getting young
people into the community and kind of
what we're doing and kind of best
practices and things I want you to get
about what you can do to bring more
young people in the family I mean in the
community because how diverse are you if
you're not considering youth it's we
have so many women's and ethnic
diversity efforts but not enough youth
and to add on to that how diverse really
is your community if you don't bring in
youth we like to think our communities
are diverse because we include women and
different people of color and even at
the Women's Open Source lunch we were
talking about how you know who decides
what's diverse and the most overlooked
group is youth we're literally hacking
into unix linux kernel's
hacking in a Minecraft making games
we're the most overlooked group and and
like a whole bunch of programs like for
one example I use a a popular program
I'm pretty sure most you guys have heard
of it it's called slack and I used this
a collaborator who among teams around
the world and we were approached and
slack about what we're doing we found
out that we legally aren't even able to
use slack because we're underage and
there's a lot of platforms like this
that put age restrictions and we
literally are stopping in the tech
community from progressing because these
age restrictions so our talk has changed
like 10 times listened to a lot of the
good talks at this conference and and we
were we thought of that one because a
guy Martin did a talk yesterday about
slack in community and we had a story
about slack and just in for slacks
purposes we could also say we talked to
them and they're trying to lower the age
limits
so that younger people can use it so we
wanted to start out talking a little bit
about who we are and why we're here but
Jim hit on most of this stuff but I'll
introduce our tech family over to the
right is my my son Phillip he's the
oldest he's 28 and he's a sysadmin and
an IT guy at school then we got hunter
right next to him he's a video game
developer and if you google open-source
gaming you'll see a lot of hunters posts
over to the left we have my son David
he's wants to be a surgeon but somehow
we're gonna tech that up I don't know
we're building cyborgs there's something
we tell this boy we were gonna we're
gonna work with brain since connections
and then we got at the bottom my
daughter Kayla and I think you've met
her but tell us a little bit more about
you Kayla
well like Jim was saying I've been
speaking at conferences since I was 11
years old and this was my biggest one at
O'Reilly özkan which I did the keynote
and that one was a group of about five
four thousand people in the room but
really it reached a bigger audience
because that's all kind of went viral
and I also had the pleasure of visiting
the White House under President Obama
and it's a lot different there now I was
also featured at the Melissa
harris-perry show and we also got to go
to the mayor of Los Angeles and that's
also the CTO yeah chief technology is
another picture a chief for diversity
the chief chief technology officer for
the United States of America is a woman
for a woman want to know that so so it
was a great role model for my daughter
I'm just meeting her and talking about
being in her position so the first thing
we want to talk about is how we do
things how what's what's our method so
Kayla how do we engage
what do we use engagement well as I
mentioned earlier on 15 so I still go to
school and every ride it to school we
usually have a discussion whether it's a
debate or just a regular conversation
about a whole different bunch of
different topics and usually we try to
relate it around Tech and I feel that
like having these talks on the way to
school on the way home it makes us
engage like the reason why kids like the
stuff is because it pertains to us we're
not just going to you know write a whole
bunch of code just for the purpose of it
it has to relate to us and I think
engagement is a crucial part in
involving youth in the tech community so
we we believe in a a lot of reverse
engineering and I think that gets a lot
of youth involved in something and it's
whatever thing that they like to do so
at Southern California Linux Expo where
I'm one of the chairs there and my kids
have been involved since the beginning
what sixteen years ago we get we started
to implement more youth programs and
we're starting to get more high schools
to come and and and you'll find that you
ask them to reverse engineer stuff and
just think how does that work how did we
get that there how do we get that it and
then it gets them started on a path that
will get them to every community we have
even some kids that are kind of kernel
developers and I mean one who's just
like idolizes Linus Torvalds and so he
was like you gotta talk to them when you
get there so we you get that engagement
and then you get them started and then
sky's the limit
next is goals what do we do with gold
well goals are a huge part of my year
and when I say goals I'm not just
talking about New Year's resolutions
that everyone sets and forgets about
during the year the goals that we set we
try to tend to set ten goals it goes
that we make for ourselves and two goals
that our dad sets and most of the time
their tech goals each year I try to
learn a new language and but although
they're not always tech they're always
they're also like personal and physical
and emotional
and these goals make me strive to be a
better person like last year my goal was
to learn JavaScript more and teach more
kids and I was able to do that a lot of
times we'll feel like man we're slacking
but when you start looking at those
goals and we do like every three or four
months we do review of your pace on your
goals and until the kids you know me oh
I've set two of their goals they can set
eight goals for the year but we'll set
two because you know you kind of want to
guide their course so if you're
mentoring or are you working with youth
or nieces nephews then having them have
some investment in their own goals is
the key thing because you know then they
think stop bossing me around I'm kind of
doing this myself
so we the thing with getting youth into
our communities is the barriers do you
feel fear in doing something with adults
and you know and a lot of people I
always ask Kayla like you're not
terrified being in front of a lot of
people that are dolt
you know the kid are the kids audiences
you know easy and she's always done
adult audiences tell us about embracing
the fear well one particular story is
when I was 12 years old my first big
audience was at PyCon in Montreal and it
was a lightning talk and when my dad
told me was you can get up on the stage
you can completely fall just trip over
this whole stage and one thing to
remember to do is just laugh at yourself
and I guess that advice worked out
because I'm here speaking in front of
all of you guys today so if we trip or
anything on this stage we are gonna
laugh we've loved any lies believe it's
gonna happen yes so that one if we've
pretty much said like the fear of doing
stuff a lot of the young developers they
are afraid of even submitting code or
and entering in a lot of these things
because like one of the kids that was a
kernel developer he he said you know his
code getting rejected was like the
biggest thing to him and yet I was like
go back go go there again keep doing
that and once they get over that then
they can do everything and so that's why
I tell them every project isn't your
first one your your best one you know
it's some things go wrong and
interviewing a lot of programmers before
they you know spoke at our conferences
the conferences we've been at one of the
main things I asked him you know is like
how'd you get started a lot of them said
I wanted you to make a video game
somewhere along the line that didn't
work and I remembered that was my first
thing when I was 10 I wanted to be like
a video game so I learned that didn't
work but it led me into so many other
way places comparing yourself to no one
Kayla tell me about that and another
thing that ties into this is imposter
syndrome I'm a victim of imposter
syndrome and I know a lot of people in
the tech community aren't victims of it
- on the way here it was an 11 hour
flight and I'm sitting here thinking on
mine like why am i being able to fly all
the way to Prague like I'm not as smart
as most of the people in this room and
literally when I was sitting in and on
fosters talk yesterday like five people
raised their hand and said that they
contributed to the Linux kernel like
we're literally contributing to the
Linux kernel and I'm pretty sure a lot
of people are capable or have already
done stuff like this so I have to
constantly remind myself to compare
myself to no one and instead motivate
myself or inspired by other people like
Reuben for example who had a great talk
oh yeah it was a great talk if you
missed a Rubens talk you know seeing a
young kid 11 years old if I'm correct
still 11 right yeah and him getting up
on stage and saying all the stuff that
he's doing if he's not in your community
if you're not you're looking at him like
yeah that was nothing Danny you know
your community is
it's not as diverse as you need it to be
the biggest thing about it this one for
me
and I don't know if you have some more
on this one to kayla is that adults of
the one thing I we we work with a lot of
students now we've started programs
around LA and hopefully around the world
so well we're dealing with a lot of
young people that are averse to tech
from the start and to get them from
ground zero to where you you know where
they want to be is a hard thing because
I know with my own kids I had to you
know stop monitoring them and in
micromanaging them and thinking they
have to take the same path as me
they take everybody takes a whole
different path to where they want to be
so if you do it your way they're
different than you and so we're that's
our big thing with schools did we learn
anything like that with some of the
students at some of the schools yes like
my dad mentioned we've been working with
schools and most of the time we realized
that a lot of these kids tend to just
need a bit of motivation and from on
there you have your own self motivation
and I think that's crucial and even
going to conferences like this I tend to
get triggered and have a whole bunch of
self motivation even going to some of
the booths like Red Hat and all the
other ones I go home and with all these
paper nothing like what am I gonna learn
next like what am I going to program yes
and a lot of the people at the booths of
the clouds and boots on our new thing is
kubernetes so we're just like what is
that and so he's probably stopped by a
ton of your boobs and grab your ear a
gang at times about that because when
high school kids that start learning
that kind of thing so from there we
start taking it to the next level so
where do we want to go from there Kayla
they're probably asking themselves okay
you told us a lot about what you're
doing a lot of things that you know we
could do what's next what's our what are
what are we doing well we're not mostly
focusing our cell
now now we're starting to focus on other
kids getting other kids involved and so
as you can see right now we're teaching
at schools and we're starting our own
company called banks family Tech which
is gonna be on Facebook soon and during
the summer of La we taught at parent
Middle School and Tom Bradley middle
school and as you can see some things
are some of our kids and teaching
basically is the next generation like we
said youth they're the overlooked group
and so directly reaching out to this
group of teaching them you know you got
to be the part of you've got to be the
new generation of the tech community and
this is part of our teaching at school
yeah you does some of these are even
young this is a class of fifth graders
and I I don't like to put down any
languages in particular because
everything serves purpose but we do
programs where they're actually learning
real code because that is a lot of stem
programs science technology engineering
and math programs in the United States
are focused on just saying we're
teaching some coding and we're not big
fans of that you know like one of the
things I really loved about rubens talk
is he was he was doing some Python right
in his and young kids can learn this now
a lot of times we use things like
scratch is a language that it's like
scratching a chalkboard
from you here because they're not really
learning life applicable languages so so
we're teaching in schools and what do we
want to do from there
we we want you to our next thing was
like how do you get involved we want
there's so many tech minds in this room
that can that can give back to the
communities there's if everyone in here
multiplied that knowledge at one school
just going to one group of kids and
getting one kid involved imagine how
many kids around this world will be
because I only tell them this
just a tool you can do whatever you want
in life there's some people that were
graphic design and that's what my son
Hunter it's my son Hunter teaching it's
these two schools that's my son David
down there helping with Hunter was more
graphic design applied it to video game
design so how we gonna that's how you
can get involved and help us so now
Kayla made this I said tell me tell us
about this one Kayla so this light is
they can dedicate it to our community as
I mentioned earlier we live in Los
Angeles but even all the way on the
other side of the world
we literally have so many familiar faces
like me and that's our friend guy and
Adrian and all these people and so being
in tech really enables a community and
that's what we're trying to put portray
and yeah these are all awesome if you a
lot of the people we've seen here today
so I gotta say we've changed his side so
many times seeing so many new faces you
know nithya talks and Kayla and the
woman's in tech talk came out with a
couple new friends and and then I was
like different people we didn't even
know we're here you know John oh you see
we see them in every city or if it stops
at the house and of course our new
friend Angela's here running this
conferencing and so community so having
my kids in this community all this time
there's so many people we can we I mean
even when we went to the White House we
there was people across the road like
hey there's so-and-so and they're in the
tech community and then they offer their
advice or anything if they know them but
imagine if more kids are involved and
get these contacts and everything like
like some of our young programmers like
Rubin get these contacts and then they
help them and they help develop them as
programmers and as developers is design
and engineers so now with all that what
are they gonna do they gonna reach out
to us yeah you guys gonna reach out to
us if you guys gonna hey guys gonna
contact us on Facebook and so there's
our Facebook that's my primary source of
contact and you can also since we have
to leave right after I have to get back
to school
you guys can shoot us to the email and
lastly you guys can for sure tweet us
because our Twitter game is about to be
a one not the other Twitter but we're
gonna be all over social media and this
is the thing we wanted to get everybody
else involved and just like you know we
want you to reach out to your
communities reach back out to us if you
if you just want to start an effort or
anything and wherever in the world this
world's a small places we've shown it's
a small place and you know we're here
and there we talk to people all over the
world all the time and get some of your
input some of the things that work for
you and if you need our help the same
thing so on behalf of myself and the
bass represent the rest of the banks
family from all the way blas angeles
california we like to say thanks thanks
for nice there hold on one second so I
want to make hold on one sec so the and
this is unscripted so but I wanna make a
deal with you so many of you know and
it's Clyde see percent in the audience
somewhere around here
have you met Clyde yet so Clyde runs all
of our training and development at the
Linux Foundation and we have
certification tests for Linux Assad mins
for kubernetes for a whole bunch of
different technology we have self-paced
training online training we would love
to offer for your classes in Los Angeles
access to that you know free testing
recertification so as you're building
out that program hopefully you know and
take us up with Adrian was on one of our
slides he's so yeah he said you guys
would love to help also we love it let's
do it we love it
thank you